How do you identify?
How do you justify a rejection of identity
ism when a pillar of the neo Marxist
strategy is to demographically replaced
the indigenous people of Europe,
London,
it's less than half ethnically English.
Um,
okay.
So let's take that question apart.
First of all,
it isn't self evident to me that it is
specifically a neo Marxist strategy to
demographically replaced the
indigenous peoples of Europe and um,
I don't think that's the strategy anyways,
even if that's the outcome because you
have to distinguish between strategy and
outcome.
Um,
the strategy and principle is to
bring in immigrants to balance out the
declining birth rate.
Now I'm not saying I agree with that.
I'm just saying that that's
what the strategy is.
A,
and then the next part of the question
is predicated on the assumption that
identitarianism is necessarily
the answer to the problem of,
um,
the problem that's being identified,
which is characterized
as excess immigration.
First of all,
we'd have to figure out exactly what
identitarianism means because it isn't
clear.
Uh,
if it means radical right
wing ethnic nationalism,
I don't think that that's going
to be particularly constructive.
If it means having a sensible discussion
about what the appropriate limits might
be on immigration,
uh,
and to think about that over the long run.
And also to have a
serious discussion about
the degree to which say is lamb and,
and the west,
the values of Islam and the
West are actually commensurate,
then that has to be,
obviously has to be done.
But,
um,
so I'm afraid that to
answer that question,
I'd have to know more about exactly
how these terms we're being,
we're being defined,
especially with regards to
identitarianism cause it's a vague word.
And.